we're going to begin with breaking news
overnight from the war in Ukraine where
the Russian military has launched a
deadly barrage of missiles across the
country Ukraine's President says these
missiles hit energy centers and
residential buildings and killed at
least six people most of them hundreds
of miles away from the front line ground
fighting MCS tayab is in dinipro that's
Central Ukraine one of the Cities
attacked overnight MTS good morning
Tony good morning to you while this is
the most serious missile and drone
attack to Target cities across Ukraine
in nearly a month but as you can see
here in denipro people really trying to
get back to life as quickly as they can
but in bhagmud russian-backed forces say
they've managed to push forward in that
embattled City
in a blistering assault a battery of
Russian missiles and drones struck
several major cities little was spared
and lives lost as Millions more were
plunged into the cold and darkness it
doesn't make sense to me how this can
happen in the 21st century this resident
says it's like we're being attacked by
wild people just Savages
all winter but Kremlin has ruthlessly
been targeting Ukraine's infrastructure
in missile and drone attacks
but it's in bakboot where the fighting
Remains the most intense
the head of the Russian mercenary group
Wagner is claiming his Fighters have
captured key urban areas
after seven grinding months of running
Street battles as the Kremlin continues
to desperately pursue its first major
territorial gain in over half a year
only a few miles away we met badja who
just returned from the front
it's tough he says really hard there are
losses but we can't win without that
losses felt no more acutely than at the
funeral of 29 year old medic Yama likely
who was killed treating injured soldiers
in a field Hospital outside bakmut
her mother cries in anguish odiana my
baby my little one
as she says her final goodbye
now as ukrainians continue to pay the
ultimate price its leaders say they're
determined to keep defending buckmut
despite the costs Gail
oh MTS that video was tough to watch you
may not speak the language but you
certainly know anguish when you hear it
that was very difficult thank you